>> IT'S SO IMPORTANT TCHUSHKIN .
PUTS THE BREAK ON.
ONE TIMER, SCORE.
WHAT A PASS. SHE A STOP FLIGHT
PLAYER.
YOU KNOW WHO HE ALEX NEW HOOK.
SECOND GAME.AT THE PRESEASON
PREDICTO DO IT NOW.ONE TIMER, H.
DEVON TOEWS WITH T TCHEMISTRY, ,
GIRARD.
AND TOEWS.
BEEN FLYING THE LAST HALF D TRI.
IN FOURTH -- THIS FOURTH LINE.S.
KNOCK HIM DOWN.
HERE THEY  HANG ON.
NUMBER TWO WAVS THE 2-1 LEAD.
THE PLAY AGAIN.
SCORE.
ALEX NEWHOOK WELCOME BACK TO THE
COLORADO AVALANCHE AS HEE
NEWHOOK.
A GOAL BLUE HAIRS.
>> MARC: AT ANY GIVEN
POINT. COUPLE OF  LET HIM DO.
>> DOWN THE SLOT AND KICKED AWAY
HOCKEY GAME.
WAS IT 8-0IT OFF.
HERTL.
TURN AROUND SHOT.
POWER PLAY GOA THAT WORK
THAT ALL THESE GUYS PUT IN.
SO NOW  LANDESKOG.
SHOT SCORED.
SEE LANDESKOG.
SO YOU'RE TRYING NOT TO SMILE
B
NET.
>> PETER: WE TALKED ABOUT. ONE.
OR SHOULD I
>> LITTLE BIT BACK AND FORTH
EARLY. LITTLE RUN